[Music]
good evening I'm Bret bear this was not
the kind of holiday greeting President
Trump was expecting from the
highest-ranking judge in the country
Supreme Court Chief Justice John Roberts
is directly contradicting the president
tonight on the subject of judicial bias
it did not take long for the President
to return fire
correspondent Kevin cork is outside the
mar-a-lago compound in West Palm Beach
tonight we're reporters spent the day
watching the president's Twitter feed
feed active again just minutes ago good
evening Kevin you're right on the money
their bread and good evening to you and
frankly this was a rare review from the
Chief Justice but I think it underscores
a fairly common frustration among
jurists that politics have absolutely no
place in the court of law the Ninth
Circuit is really something we have to
take a look at because it's not fair
what began as a president's sharp
critique of the Ninth Circuit late
yesterday today careened off the pillars
of the US Supreme Court but Chief
Justice John Roberts chiding the
president for injecting politics into
the courts we do not have Obama judges
or Trump judges he wrote Bush judges or
Clinton judges what we have is an
extraordinary group of dedicated judges
doing their level best to do equal right
to those appearing before them that
independent judiciary is something we
should all be thankful for the president
responded on Twitter sorry Chief Justice
John Roberts but you do indeed have
Obama judges and they have a much
different point of view than the people
who are charged with the safety of our
country Roberts review comes after Judge
John tiger and Obama appointee ruled
against the administration's plans to
impose new restrictions on asylum cases
a move the president seemed to think was
politically motivated
perhaps because like rulings from Obama
appointed judges in Hawaii and Michigan
the president's latest policy plans were
again halted at least temporarily I
don't know the frustration is anything
new but I do think it's kind of
heightened it seems like almost every
policy rule regulation or law that comes
out right now gets immediately
challenged mr. Trump has been
mr. Roberts before but it is rare that
the chief justice on the highest court
in the land would return volley albeit
subtly Justice Roberts really led us
down
what he did with Obamacare was
disgraceful
there was nothing subtle about the
president's support for Saudi Arabia
today calling the kingdom's low oil
prices a big tax cut for America and the
world no mention of Riyadh's possible
role in the murder of journalist jamal
khashoggi or the building pressure to
increase sanctions on the Saudi monarchy
a decision that's drawn widespread
condemnation with Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham writing one thing I
learned during the Obama years is that
when you look the other way regarding
problems in the Middle East it seldom
works out while the questions continue
to swirl about exactly what happened to
the Saudi journalists the White House
dealt with an entirely different set of
questions of its own yesterday
delivering responses to a series of
queries from the Muller team including
according to Axios whether the president
knew about Don juniors trumped our
meeting with Russians no confirmation
yet from the White House on that report
which also suggested that the Muller
team Brett asked the president when who
was then candidate Trump about comments
he made on the campaign trail about the
Russians looking into secretary
Clinton's missing 33,000 emails read
back to you Kevin cork outside the
winter White House Kevin thanks